noch jemand macht heute Schlagzeilen
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach der
Plan ist einen krankenhauskarlschlag 689
Kliniken stehen auf der Kippe diese
sollen auf ambulanzniveau
heruntergestuft werden das bedeutet
obwohl diese Krankenhäuser noch so
heißen wird dort nur noch ambulant
behandelt Rettungswagen dürfen Sie also
nicht mehr anfahren Ärzte und Kommunen
schlagen Alarm diese Reform dürfe so
nicht kommen auch wenn im
Gesundheitssystem finanziell immer mehr
aus dem Ruder läuft wir haben der auf
dem Land lebt der könnte dann eventuell
nur noch Patient zweiter Klasse sein mit
langen Fahrten bis zum nächsten
richtigen Krankenhaus das also jetzt
unser Thema bei viertel nach acht Frau
Wagenknecht haben sie Sorge dass wir
somit vielleicht eine zwei
klassenmedizin bekommen könnten das also
gerade Menschen auf dem Land abgehängt
werden könnten also wir haben ja längst
eine zwei klassenmedizin muss man auch
sagen also Kassenpatient wartet manchmal
drei Monate eher irgendwie ein Facharzt
zu Gesicht bekommen da sie die Zustände
im Gesundheitssystem sind ja schon
schlecht und alle erinnern uns noch in
der corona-zeit hat man es fast jeden
Abend die Bilder gezeigt von den
überfüllten Intensivstationen damals hat
man uns weiß gemacht das seien die
ungeimpften in Wahrheit war es natürlich
nicht die mangelnde Impfung sondern es
war der jahrelange Bettenabbau es war
der jahrelang hingenommene
Personalmangel und ich muss sagen ich
finde das den blanken Irrsinn wenn
lauter was Antwort auf diese Zustände
die ja bedeuten wir brauchen mehr
Pflegekräfte wir brauchen mehr Personal
wir brauchen eine bessere Ausstattung
wenn die Antwort von ihm heißt wir
machen jetzt noch mehr kaltschlag und
natürlich ist das für Menschen auf dem
Land das kann die Frage von Leben oder
Tod entscheiden wie weit das Krankenhaus
Weg ist also jeder weiß dass beim
Schlaganfall beim Herzinfarkt es geht um
Minuten und wenn man dann also erstmal
irgendwie noch eine halbe Stunde oder
eine Dreiviertelstunde fahren muss dann
ist es rum und ich finde das so
unverantwortlich und mich hat auch
erschrocken ich habe letztens gelesen
wir sind schon jetzt in Deutschland im
Vergleich zu anderen westeuropäischen
Ländern eines der Länder mit der
niedrigsten Lebenserwartung also die
Leute werden wir uns schon immer weniger
alt als es in anderen Ländern der Fall
ist und ehrlich gesagt das noch durch
solche Maßnahmen zu forcieren also das
finde ich wirklich völlig
unverantwortlich wir erklären Sie sich
diese Maßnahme diese geplante Maßnahme
ist noch nicht so ist muss man sagen
geht es ums Geld sparen worum geht es so
ja Lauterbach geht es ja immer darum ich
meine man muss ja auch wissen Lauterbach
ist zwar jetzt erst seit dieser Ampel
Gesundheitsminister aber er war ja
vorher schon Berater einer
Gesundheitsministerin nämlich damals
unter Gerhard Schröder und da hat
eigentlich das Unheil angefangen da hat
man nämlich die Krankenhäuser umgestellt
auf Rentabilität auf Rendite also mit
den Fallpauschalen also da ging es dann
nicht mehr darum dass ein Krankenhaus
Kranke bestmöglich behandelt sondern
dann war plötzlich der Anreiz wir müssen
mit den Kranken bestmögliche Geschäfte
machen also wir müssen möglich solche
OPs machen mit denen wir viel verdienen
und Kranke mit denen man nicht so viel
verdienen kann zum Beispiel Kinder das
ist ja ein Problem der Kindermedizin die
Kapazitäten wurden gnadenlos abgebaut
und da ist Lauterbach unmittelbar mit
verantwortlich und dass dieser Mann
überhaupt noch Gesundheitsminister ist
ist eigentlich schon ein Skandal weil
der hat nur Pleiten bisher hingelegt in
seiner ganzen Zeit wo er irgendwelche
Verantwortung hat ich würde ja gerne
noch ergänzen gerade weil gerade auch
die Versorgung eigentlich auch von
Müttern und Kindern finde ich ganz
dramatisch also abseits davon was man
jetzt noch abbauen will erleben wir ja
schon seit in den letzten 15 Jahren
wurden ungefähr 230 Geburtsstationen
bereits geschlossen das heißt die
Versorgung gerade für Neugeborene und
für schwangere Frauen
wurde quasi systematisch abgebaut und
zwar genau unter diesem Aspekt weil es
sich nämlich für die Krankenhäuser nicht
lohnt also Geburten sind quasi mit dem
kann man kein Geld verdienen kosten Geld
in manchen Regionen gehen deswegen z.B
auch massiv die Kaiserschnitte nach oben
nicht weil es medizinisch notwendig ist
sondern weil Frauen jetzt eigentlich
Angst haben ob sie noch rechtzeitig in
eine Klinik kommen denn wenn die nächste
Geburtsstation eine Stunde entfernt ist
dann mache ich im Zweifel lieber einen
geplanten Kaiserschnitt weil ich mich
nicht traue sozusagen auf eine
natürliche Geburt zu warten und das
heißt wir haben plötzlich und ein
Kaiserschnitt ist eine OP das heißt wir
haben eine Unterversorgung jetzt schon
vor allen Dingen für Neugeborene und für
schwangere Frauen wo ist denn da bitte
unsere unsere Frauenministerin irgendwie
um sich darüber aufzuregen die
unterschreiben das alles und seit Jahren
geht das schon so fragen wir mal den
Mann in unserer Runde fühlen Sie sich
gut versorgt gut aufgehoben in unserem
Gesundheitssystem also ich finde man
stellt auf jeden Fall fest in den
letzten Jahren und ich denke das hat
langsam angefangen deswegen kann man
auch schon von fast Jahrzehnten sprechen
dass ich da ähm definitiv etwas
verändert hat also nicht so zurückdenke
in meine jüngere Zeit und mein 20ern und
auch davor wenn man so einen Termin
braucht beim Arzt ja dann ging das
eigentlich relativ fix und heute dauert
es wirklich sehr sehr lange und wenn man
dann auch mal wirklich akut krank ist
wie mir kürzlich passiert und dann man
einfach mal erscheint ja beim Hausarzt
beispielsweise was vor 20 Jahren
eigentlich noch relativ kein Problem
gewesen ist nur man regelrecht
verscheucht ja weil man hat ja keinen
Termin gehabt und das geht ja so nicht
und man ist eigentlich die ganze Zeit am
Husten und am keuchen und die
Halsschmerzen und sonst irgendwas und
ich finde da ist das schon deutlich
spürbar aber ich kann nicht wirklich
sagen was da so die Lösungsansätze sind
weil dieses Thema
sie leben auch in Berlin in der
Hauptstadt natürlich eine große Auswahl
an Krankenhäusern an Ärzten Frau was was
sie sind ja im Rheinland groß geworden
da ist vielleicht ist dann wenn man auf
dem Land ist nicht immer ganz so einfach
wollen Sie lieber wenige Kliniken so wie
der Gesundheitsminister sagt diese dann
aber optimiert mit dem Risiko dass der
Weg dorthin sehr sehr weit ist also
erstmal bei uns im Bergischen ist es
tatsächlich so wir sind auch noch sehr
gut aufgestellt also wenn ich jetzt
daran denke ich wohne zwar richtig in
der Pampa aber trotzdem wenn ich 15
Minuten Auto fahre kann ich für
verschiedene Kliniken erreichen das
heißt wenn da ich wenn da tatsächlich
parallel Strukturen vorhanden sind und
man das sinnvoll irgendwie
zusammenfassen kann und das wirklich der
Qualität und vor allem wurde der
Patienten gehen meine Güte so dass dass
das glaube ich aber nicht und wenn ich
ein bisschen weiter bei uns ins
ländliche reinschaue vor allem wo ich
die Bevölkerung älter ist was ja auch
noch mal zusammen kommt wo es einfach
super Komplex sie haben zum Teil noch
nicht mal öffentlich Nahverkehr vor Ort
und dann sich zu überlegen wenn dann
noch Häuser schließt wie soll das
funktionieren kann ich klappen ich bin
aber auch hier der Meinung der Runde
tatsächlich das war so ein typischer
Lauterbach halt eigentlich hat er gerade
auch anderes zu tun ne also wenn auch
mit Ärzten sprichst was ich auch auf
Tour die sprechen auch die sind auch
überlastet was das Ganze Bürokratie
Thema angeht die kostet ja Stunden Tage
Wochen ihres Lebens und das werden wir
Dinge wo man dran ist einfach dass man
Digitalisierung zulässt das war Zeit
dass es spart Ressourcen das ist
wesentlich effizienter oder auch dieses
Thema Studienplätze ich weiß noch als
ich Abi gemacht habe alle die Medizin
studiert haben ins Ausland die sind nach
Ungarn die sind nach Österreich das geht
nicht das kann nicht funktionieren also
ich würde mir wirklich auch als junger
Mensch wünschen ja der ja noch weiß dass
er noch ein paar Jahrzehnte versorgt
werden muss dass wir mal diese an diese
Druckpunkte hat vor allen Dingen aber
finde ich müsste man einfach mal genau
schauen wo versichert eigentlich das
ganze Geld mit Verlaub unsere
Krankenkassenbeiträge steigen seit
Jahren und die Leistungen sinken ihm
geben genauso und das seit Jahren das
heißt aber irgendwo geht dieses Geld ja
verloren ja das heißt irgendwie wir
haben immer weniger Krankenhäuser immer
weniger Pflegepersonal der Bedarf steigt
die Kosten steigen wo versickert
eigentlich das Geld das würde mich
einfach mal interessieren